good morning belief nation my name is
Lily and my one word is extraordinary I
believe that every single human being is
capable of extraordinary things so to
help you on your journey today's message
is be brilliant over to you Floyd
Mayweather a man that has never been in
a boxing ring is in the ring with the
best ever that's what you talk that's
what you describe yourself as being I
don't ascribe myself we must realize men
like women line numbers don't lie 49 I
know not just 49 don't listen to me
whether that's didn't didn't broke every
record in boxing when we get to talk
about highest gate even when it was like
right now they said all mayweather fight
didn't sell up well you know woman when
they do sell out I think I read
somewhere like you know that ligated
reached like eighty something man for
this fight already we already had sixty
something million for those are saying
that Mayweather is not doing numbers
anymore far as taking the less
punishment I took less punishment than
any fighter not just best defense let's
talk about offense the most accurate
fighter of all time on the outside the
ring it's not just about being in the
inside ring
I already already conquered that I was
I'm even smarter on the outside you know
I have to be a genius to even make this
to even make a fight like this happen
so what what does that say about me for
making this it says that you it says
that you're a brilliant businessman not
just a great box so that and that's what
I always spoke about that's what I
always spoke about I gave my credit
about what I do in the ring but I don't
get my credit about what I do on the
outside you can't have massive success
unless you're willing to put in insane
amounts of hard work there's no denying
that Mayweather is brilliant at what he
does it's also not a surprise that he
puts in a lot of effort outside of the
ringg anybody who is very successful you
will see that they do not get there
without insane amount of hard work I
look at my own journey and every time I
put out a video you guys give me so much
love you're saying how much I have grown
and how amazing it is to see my growth
rate and it's true I have grown a
significant amount over the last five
months but what you're not seeing is the
insane amounts of hard work that I'm
putting it behind the scenes it took me
over a hundred takes just to do the
intro video for my unlocking Lilly
series I have over 350 unlisted videos
that ended up on the cutting room floor
that you guys will never see and the
reason why I'm telling you this is that
I want you to know whatever it is that
you want to do whether if you want to be
a boxer you want to be a speaker or an
entrepreneur it's possible all you have
to do is put in the hard work now that
is a lot easier said than done you're
gonna be forced to make some difficult
decisions to reprioritize your life you
have to make some sacrifices you might
not be able to go to every friend's
birthday party you might have to push
through a lot of pain to persevere when
I did my intro video after the 50th time
I wasn't sure if I was gonna be able to
do it I didn't realize it was going to
be so hard and what's even harder is
that I wasn't sure if I was able to
sustain this amount of hard work but
something inside of me gave me that
persevere is to pick myself up and do it
again 50 more times until I got it right
and that's what's gonna happen to you
you're gonna have moments that you feel
like you can't go on you're gonna have
moments that you have depleted all sorts
of energy but you have to find that
perseverance in you to push through and
you're watching this video for a reason
because you want to get inspired but at
the same time I know that deep down
inside you know that you have what it
takes to achieve the same level of
success as a people that you're inspired
all you have to do is put in hard work
dedication and hustle day after day week
after week month after month and year
after year and you too can be brilliant
so the question of the day is what is
that one thing you want to be brilliant
at write in the comments below and I'll
be sure to join in on the discussion I'm
a special shout out for Clifford Starks
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of evans book your one word and I hope
you're loving the read as much as I did
so thank you so much for watching I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
when I came to former one in trying to
get again to form almost was tough I had
to win everything I was led to believe I
had to win every championship so I had
to make sure that I studied about the
car every change that I made that I had
to write it down and study it have a
castle of the home of all the changes I
made of all my setups so when I got the
phone one changed from rhobar know
exactly what changes that's gonna make
to the car and so I had to really build
up a good understanding of mechanics and
I think you know when I got to McLaren
my fitness level had to take another
step to another level so I was training
ridiculous amount of hours a week and
which I hated her and spending a lot of
time at the factory would sit down with
an NG I had would have probably four to
five probably for engineering meetings
every day that's McLaren this is before
my first season after my GP two season
two to understand all the different
scenarios the race strategy is the tire
tires the steering wheel there was
incredible amount of information I
didn't have to do it before before I
just get in the car in front of gb2 and
and now I could you know do a couple map
read a couple of maps trying to
understand where the tracks going and
work with it set up but perform one was
tons and tons of information and and
that was really the biggest step that I
had to make I had a steering wheel took
home and I had to study it I looked at
it every every morning and every Union
tried to close my eyes and know when
switches were and and and obviously just
to get enough to speed in my first eight
test days I had trying to catch get on
the pace and not make mistakes and have
the fitness level to just keep it up
that was the biggest difference done for
me and you know I gots my first race and
you know I was fourth came forth from
the first race I was ready because I I
really did
no I couldn't I look I couldn't look
back and say I wish I'd done some more
that because I did everything I could I
came to the the mindset when I was in
film school marked that I did not want
to be a one-and-done I not want to be a
flash in the pan I wanted to be here for
the long haul
it wouldn't encourage south the great
character style what I'm doing is doing
press was one of his last times Ron his
journals asked him you wanted a greatest
master filmmakers of all time what else
you still have to learn and Kurosawa
said I still have the universe hmm to
learn so I was in film school you know
and that blew my mind the baddest
[ __ ] right he's 85 83 84
he says he saucy saucy University learn
as far as storytelling yeah that really
hit me like you know you you really got
a like the jazz term you got you got to
stay in the woodshed you got a [ __ ] you
know and constantly be honest perfecting
your crap and never get to the point
that you you trick yourself of thinking
that you know it all yeah it's a life
long journey you know what I mean
distorts to tell stories how to craft
them just be a good storytelling and you
do that by having a body of work so it's
always been on the body of work that if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details